the royals get their opening day starter
from a year ago back
25 year old brad keller who tested
positive for covert in early july and
then
he was ready to go he was cleared but
kansas city wanted to make sure he was
fully built
up and really ready to be an impactful
starter again before they cut him loose
to arizona entire 2018
season that is a liner to left and
diving attempt from gordon but
that's down and a bounce and a two out
hit from baez
tyler chatwood back in the rotation this
year after spending much of last season
in the bullpen
boy has he been good just one run in 12
and two-thirds so far this year
he's been incredible for the cubs and
david ross we talked to him today said
hey he came in
he's taken a claim to a rotation spot so
lair bangs a line drive base it into
center
he says the key for him is he just
started swinging with more aggression
concerted effort to do damage and i mean
with a frame and the strength
that you said you saw early on when you
faced it
perez reaches out pokes a base hit the
other way
two out single for sal perez solar is
headed for third and the royals have
them cornered with one god
with the cleanup man ryan o'hearn coming
up
horn hits it sharply pass the diving
horner into right center to give the
royals the early lead
so three consecutive singles for kansas
city well hearn drives in solo aaron
it's one nothing
here you go franco pulls the ball to
left center field and the
first year royal drops one in the gap
that will make its way to the wall
the question with this guy has never
been talent it's always been about
consistency the royals are hoping they
can capture something here on a one-year
deal
the top of the order and whitmer field
with two gone under the radar star
and all he does is hit and get hit
breaking ball lifted down the left field
line
schwarber is going back on it he turns
and watches it hit
off the foul pole two-run home run with
merrifield and the royals leading three
nothing
there you go joe look how excited those
virtual fans are cups have had their
starter go seven
full odyssey on the first pitch grounds
of base hit through the middle
odyssey thinking two here's the throw
not in time
and you see some of that talent ability
and
just raw athleticism that alberto
modesty possesses
here's gordon he lifts a fly ball to
center field that sends hat back
he's still going he's on a sprint he's
out of room it's off the wall
monday into score and a double from alex
gordon makes it four nothing
one and two on franco now now the pitch
swing and a shot to left field backhoe
schwarber looking up and that ball is
out of here it's into the cup bullpen
a low line drive home run just gets over
the fence a two-run homer for franco
that's his third homer
on the year and the royals lead is six
to nothing and this time
it to right and he's got his first hit
as hayward can't pull it in
lopez coming for the plate he'll score
and there it is the first major league
hit for nick heath
no better feeling no better feeling you
all he will always remember
his first major league hit
so air waits on a breaking ball grounds
it to third
palm goes to first it's eight nothing as
solaire brings home a run
there's salvi hitting one toward the gap
in left center field
on the run the center field are diving
hap can't come up with it against byum
rolls to the edge of the track
salvi's got an rbi double and another
extra base hit for the royals
wit scores and it's nine nothing
holy cow this is pretty impressive
it's another 2-2 it's
pulled over third and down the line base
it for perez mirrorfield can really run
he hits third and
he's headed home on a double from perez
and they lead a 10
nothing double door perez with his third
hit over the first five innings
strokes one into the gap in left center
field that one will make its way to the
warning trap
perez chugging home i know hearn has a
double
11 runs on 15 hits and his season debut
brad keller
five shutout innings with seven
strikeouts
what the royals have been waiting for
there their ace their opening day gotta
miss some time with the coven 19
and came back strong as ever five
innings three hits
seven punch out so layer with two gone
and the base is empty that is a little
bit up two down in the royals half of
the seventh royals up 11 nothing
there's a high fly ball got under a
little bit will it carry out of here
back to deep left center way back and
that ball is
gone he does it he homers against the
cubs
on a 1-0 pitch jorge solaire his third
homer on the year
and it's an even dozen for the royals
they lead 12-nothing
fastball turned around left center field
and we'll drop in for a hit in front of
schwarber allowing phillips to come in
the score
garatini on the line to center heath
will
slide and can't pull it in and the cubs
are going to break up the shutout
[Applause]
giratini on the line to center heath
will slide
and can't pull it in and the cubs are
going to break up the shutout
presumes here's a base hit up the middle
schwarber around third he's going to
score
and the cubs score again
nico hoyer getting a run scoring single
up the middle
and the cubs trail 13-2
[Music]
high fly by the left center field off of
the bed a half
heath to the wall to make the catch and
end the
you hope that he's okay on a night where
he's made his first career major league
start
got his first career major league hit
and then he makes that catch and good to
see him to his feet to finish off
tonight